[Musica]
[Applauso]
pensiamo un attimo a cosa significa
cambiare
il fatto è che cambiare a un'etimologia
molto particolare deriva dal greco campi
che significa piega a curvatura cambiare
quindi significa dare una direzione
diversa qualcosa
ecco spesso tutti abbiamo avuto almeno
una volta nella nostra vita la
sensazione magari anche spiacevole che
le nostre le nostre esistenze siano
decise dalle circostanze e che una volta
presa la decisione si intraprenda una
specie di percorso obbligato dei binari
un percorso obbligato da cui è difficile
è difficile cambiare direzione
io non ho una storia di riscatto
personale raccontarvi oppure dei casi
aziendali particolari da analizzare con
voi però voglio raccontarvi una storia è
una storia che qualcun altro in passato
ha raccontato a me perché è vero che noi
siamo il prodotto delle esperienze che
facciamo ma siamo anche la somma delle
storiche incontriamo nella nostra vita e
che per qualche motivo facciamo nostre
diventano parte di noi tutti noi
conosciamo questa fotografia o perlomeno
ci è familiare anche se non sappiamo
dire chi l'ha scattata o di preciso
l'anno in cui è stata scattata la
sappiamo collocare in un periodo storico
che è quello della della grande
depressione che ha colpito gli stati
uniti e poi il resto del mondo
dopo il crollo della borsa del 1929
questa foto è talmente famosa è talmente
un'icona è talmente radicata
nell'immaginario comune che quando si
tratta di raccontare qualcosa che parli
di quel periodo storico
molte persone descrivono questa
fotografia magari anche senza senza
saperlo senza rendersene conto
molte meno persone però sanno chi l'ha
scattata e qual è la storia di questa
fotografia
l'autore di questa foto anzi l'autrice è
una donna si chiama dorotea lei
dorotea nasce nel 1895 a hoboken nel new
jersey esattamente davanti a new york
forse io pensavo che il fatto di nascere
così vicino a una metropoli così grande
come new york potesse offrire chissà
quali opportunità invece ho scoperto che
in realtà la provincia americana di fine
ottocento non era proprio questo
carnevale di rio è appunto comunque sia
dorotea nasce da una famiglia di
discendenza tedesca ea 7 anni si ammala
di polio l'appoggio lo sappiamo adesso
un pochino meno perché non è più una
malattia così diffusa provoca delle
paralisi che possono colpire varie parti
del corpo e dorotea viene colpito in
particolare agli arti inferiori e si
ritroverà con una doppia valenza
evidente che la accompagnerà per tutta
per tutta la sua vita in seguito da
adulta
dorotea parlerà della polio come della
cosa più importante che vi sia mai
capitata che mi ha formato mi ha guidato
mia istruita mi ha aiutato e mi ha
umiliata e nel corso di tutta la sua
carriera dorotea l'hang non si scatterà
mai nemmeno un autoscatto l'unico selphy
che è arrivato di lei che è arrivato
fino a noi sono quelle che lei stessa si
è scattata al piede destro che si può
vedere deformato dalla dalla paralisi
avuta avuta da bambina ammalarsi di
poliomelite alla fine all'inizio del
novecento voleva dire tante cose
era una malattia che miteva moltissime
vittime e chi riusciva a sopravvivere
quindi a guarire diventava quello che
si chiamava il povero storpio dove
storpio era anche sinonimo di persona
poco intelligente si associava un
qualche tipo di ritardo mentale invece
dorotea cresce e diventa adulta
nonostante sia una studentessa poco più
che mediocre e la madre vuole spingerà
gli studi per diventare maestra per
diventare insegnante convinta che questo
tipo di professione potesse assicurarle
un futuro dignitoso
nonostante appunto la malattia subita
lei però che ha ereditato un certo senso
estetico dalla dalla nonna materna
diventa fotografa si trasferisce a new
york dove comincia a lavorare come
apprendista in uno studio fotografico e
poi ancora giovanissima compie un altro
cambiamento da sola attraversa gli stati
uniti si trasferisce a san francisco
dove apre il proprio studio fotografico
e comincia a scattare ritratte le
persone qui c'è una cosa carina che
vorrei raccontare che possiamo ricordare
anche noi forse guardando le foto
vecchie dei nostri nonni o bisnonni che
in quegli anni nei primi del novecento
la fotografia come il cinema erano la
grande novità tecnologica di quel tempo
e quindi tutti volevano provarla e si
poteva in quegli anni appunto si poteva
riuscire a capire il ceto sociale delle
persone in base al tipo di fotografia
che si facevano scattare i ricchi
avevano questi ritratti di tre quarti
magari un po spostati a mezzo busto di
profilo mentre le pressione un pochino
meno abbienti avevano questi foto
ritratti totale a campo campo totale con
magari con la moglie o il marito accanto
ecco dorotea cominciò a scattare a
scattare fotografie
comincia a scattare fotografie ma presso
le cose cambiano perché appunto dopo il
crollo del 29 non ci sono più molti
soldi per farsi scattare fotografie e
quindi decide di aderire
al progetto della fsa la farm security
administration che era quel progetto
dell'odine di del presidente roosevelt
che si incaricava di spostare da una
parte all'altra degli stati uniti
centinaia di migliaia di contadini
poverissimi seguendo la stagionalità
delle culture cercando di assicurare
loro di che vivere non sempre le cose
andavano bene perché perché appunto
spesso questi contadini vivevano in
condizioni poverissime e anche aggravate
da delle particolari condizioni
meteorologiche sfavorevoli che in quegli
anni si erano verificate insieme a molti
altri fotografi che poi sarebbero
diventati altrettanti fanno altrettanto
famosi dorate al hang comincia a girare
per gli stati uniti scattando fotografie
e comincia a documentare appunto le
condizioni di questi contadini
poverissimi che vivevano in condizioni
di totale indigenza un siamo nel
febbraio del 1936 un giorno dorotea
comincia sta guidando verso casa sta
tornando a casa dopo una giornata di
lavoro è stanca fa freddo piove una
brutta giornata sta guidando attraverso
questi campi completamente inariditi
quando vede un cartello campo per la
raccolta di piselli lì per lì non
tira dritto e appunto è stanca e stata
una lunga giornata dopo qualche
chilometro però ci ripensa e con una
svolta per nulla metaforica fa proprio
un inversione a u con la sua auto torna
indietro fino al a questo a questo campo
della della raccolta di piselli lascia
la macchina a bordo strada prende la
macchina fotografica e scende comincia
incamminarsi li nota un'automobile con
una tenda che di fatto è la casa di una
famiglia che non ha nient'altro appunto
che una vecchia automobile e un telo a
modi di tendone per ripararsi dal freddo
dell'inverno e si avvicina e nota questa
donna che sta allattando un figlio
il suo ultimo figlio si avvicina e le
chiede chi sia in realtà questa donna si
chiama florence thompson ma il suo nome
verrà reso noto soltanto molti altri
molti anni più tardi lì per lì dorotea
il florence cominciano a parlare lei gli
chiede chi sia lei si rivela soltanto
come una madre di sette figli che vive
appunto in condizioni di totale povertà
e che sta sopravvivendo mangiando i
pochi piselli congelati che si trovano
ancora nel campo le chiede il permesso
di scattare qualche fotografia al
momento florence non è molto d'accordo
non vuole essere fotografata
ma dorate alla convince spiegando che
quella fotografia potrebbe cambiare in
non soltanto la sua condizione ma magari
aiutare anche a cambiare la percezione
che l'opinione pubblica americana di
quegli anni aveva dei contadini poveri
cambiare un po quella comunque la
mentalità tutta protestante per cui il
successo negli affari è successo nella
vita era un segnale della della grazia
divina acconsente e dorotea scatta una
serie di 5 fotografie su cui spicca
insieme ai suoi bambini su cui però
spicca questo primo piano questo
ritratto che diventa immediatamente in
famosissima nel momento in cui florence
la consegna alle agenzie di stampa e
diventa un'icona diventa appunto
una foto storica che oggi tutti noi
conosciamo è appunto questo porta a un
cambiamento un cambiamento nell'opinione
pubblica che in realtà è attuale ancora
oggi in realtà dorotea non è stata la
sola a interpretare questo cambiamento a
portare avanti questo cambiamento ma
trovo che anche grazie alla sua storia
personale sia quella che incarna meglio
questa idea di cambiamento anche per via
della appunto della sua esperienza
perché dovrete avere una donna che
avrebbe avuto mille buoni motivi per non
cambiare a partire dalla sua condizione
personale avrebbe potuto rimanere a new
york a fare l'apprendista oa san
francisco a scattare autoritratti
avrebbe potuto diventare maestra come
avrebbe voluto sua madre oppure avrebbe
anche potuto non liberarsi mai di quell
etichetta di povera storpia che le era
stata appiccicata quando era appena una
bambina ed ecco io quando penso alla sua
storia penso a tutte le dorotea che ci
sono al mondo
penso sempre una cosa qual è la mia
scusa per non cambiare grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]